[Applause]
a peak hour panic in one of hong kong's
busiest districts dozens becoming
trapped in a well-known shopping centre
after a fire broke out during lunchtime
rush
there was thick smoke billowing out of
the world trade center in causeway bay
firefighters trying to reach dozens of
people stuck on a podium and the roof of
the 38th story skyscraper
hundreds of others becoming trapped
inside while fumes filled a dining area
eventually all 770 were rescued
our firemen
discovered a heavily smoked log the fire
scene was heavily smoke locked at time
of arrival
so
to a fireman we found it
it is
one of the reason may lead to the
distress to the occupants inside the
building
authorities say the fire started in the
meter room on a lower level of the
building
an investigation is underway into
exactly what caused the fire the manual
alarm and sprinkler systems had been
disabled on the first five floors
because of renovation works the fire
department said it was only alerted to
this after the fire had broken out
this all happened in a popular shopping
area in the run-up to the holidays some
of those who were trapped would have
been out with their colleagues for
christmas lunch it's caused plenty of
chaos and distress and there will be
many people demanding answers brit
clinic al jazeera hong kong